my trainer Jersey gregoric uh  he has a beautiful short saying where he  says  hard choices easy life  choices hard life so what he means by  that is if you make the hard choices in  the short term like oh I shouldn't eat  bad carbs or processed foods or I should  go ahead and do the workout which is  difficult I don't feel like doing it  then in the long term I'm going to have  an easy life but if I make the easy  choices in a short time it's a short  term but I'm going to stay out drinking  I'm going to go party I'm not going to  do my work right now I'm not going to  meditate whatever it is then in the long  term you're going to have a very  difficult life you will not have built  up that self-discipline so that is my  second heuristic for decision making